et
confusion et incertitudes après
tchernobyl les européens s'étaient mis
d'accord soit disant en fait à cause de
l'italie l'accord pour prendre des
précautions contre les produits lire a
lié l'accord n'a pas du lieu nous
écouterons les explications de jacques
delors le président de la commission
européenne
confusion et incertitudes en france
aussi quel nuage quand est-il passé
quelles conséquences
les soviétiques sont trop discrets alain
carré les scientifiques pardon sont trop
discrets
alain carignon ministre de
l'environnement est l'invité de ce
journal en direct de grenoble tennis le
no à des grands jours il a balayé lend
hier soir en demi-finale à forrest hill
en deux sets
ce soir il retrouve un revenant en
finale villa l'hommage de toute une
ville à à gaston defferre les
marseillais sont venus très nombreux
saluer affectueusement la dépouille de
leur mère
la chronique cet été fière de bernard
marchetti un poilus de la grande guerre
à qui on avait promis la médaille
militaire
l' affaire avait éclaté le 11 novembre
dernier sa médaille il a fini par
l'obtenir
le festival de cannes un peu de recul
noël mamère a vécu pour la première fois
les folie cannoise il nous adresse une
lettre à la fin de ce journal la météo
ou encore des incertitudes sur le nord
beau temps sur le sud les prévisions de
laurent bouvier dans quelques minutes
aujourd'hui dimanche 11 mai les otages
français détenus au liban
marcel carton marcel fontaine michel
seurat jean paul kauffmann et l'équipe
d'antenne 2 philippe rochot aurel cornéa
georges en scène et jean louis normandin
n'ont toujours pas été libérés camille
sonntag' l'homme de 84 ans enlevée en
début de semaine et dont l'enlèvement
n'a toujours pas été revendiqué reste
prisonnier lui aussi bonjour les
conséquences de la catastrophe de
tchernobyl n'ont pas fini de nous
étonner
il y a l'inquiétude que l'explosion de
cette centrale nucléaire soviétique
continue de susciter exemple un
quatrième mort en union soviétique
autre exemple à kiev on le sait
maintenant il règne une psychose de la
radioactivité
il ya ensuite l'incertitude et la
confusion en europe
le problème est simple un nuage
radioactif à cause de la catastrophe
bien sûr un nuage radioactif à survoler
l'europe
il faut donc prendre des mesures de
précaution mais les européens sont
incapables d'abord de mesurer la
radioactivité de la même manière ils
sont aussi incapables de se mettre
d'accord pour empêcher l'entrée en
europe des produits frais en provenance
des pays de l'est
ce matin on croyait l'accord acquis à
bruxelles en fin de matinée tout était
remis en cause
maryse mano il s'agissait d'interdire
les produits laitiers les fruits et
légumes et les produits de la mer pour
lesquels la corde et 12 ministres est
nécessaire pour la viande dans
l'importation est interdite depuis le 7
mai la commission avait pleins pouvoirs
mais cette nuit c'est l'italie qui a
fait capoter l'accord
un rejeton les seuil de radio activité
proposée par la commission
elle les juge trop élevés jacques delors
déçu rejettent la responsabilité de
l'échec sous les ministres et
scientifiques ne sont pas d'accord entre
eux sur les conséquences de cet accident
sur les niveaux de radioactivité qui
sont dangereux mais moi dans ma
responsabilité de président de la
commission
j'ai pensé qu'il fallait prendre des
précautions provisoire nous avons deux
genres de mesures à prendre à nos
frontières extérieures à nous les 12
pays européens devons suspendre les
importations pendant une période limitée
mais dans le commerce entre les deux
pays
il faut qu'on soit d'accord voyez par
exemple qu'un pays membre interdisent
sous ce prétexte les achats venant d'un
autre pays
c'est à ce moment là que les normes de
sécurité entrent en ligne de compte
car s'il faut les pays ne sont pas
d'accord sur les mers normes de sécurité
ce qu'ils ont et veulent les normes les
plus sévères ont refusé des importations
venant d'un autre pays membres de la
communauté qui pointent vers la
difficulté concrètement cela veut dire
que les produits de listes peuvent
toujours entrer dans la communauté non
pas les viandes qui représentent une
grande partie de notre commerce mais le
reste oui mais je pense de lundi en vain
le conseil des ministres mettra d'accord
en tout cas à moi dans ma responsabilité
j'ai fait un possible et qu'on a eu des
informations nécessaires encore une fois
il s'agit de mesures provisoires pour la
santé des gens ensuite nous pouvons
réfléchir ensemble aux conséquences d'un
accident
le premier du genre il y a ensuite la
confusion et l'incertitude en france on
nous a d'abord dit aucune inquiétude le
nuage n'est pas passé en france ensuite
on a dit oui il est passé mais comme il
ne pleuvait pas ce n'est pas grave du
tout puis après on a dit la
radioactivité diminue en france
étonnant puisqu'on ne nous avait jamais
dit qu'elle avait augmenté
alors où est la vérité et pourquoi la
cache ton jacques violet on nous a menti
quinze jours après la catastrophe et des
déclarations contradictoires
nous apprenons en france que le nuage
n'a pas épargné l'hexagone et que les
retombées diodes radioactifs notamment
ont été plus importantes qu'annoncées
sur toute la france
le professeur pellerin indique
aujourd'hui que jusqu'au 5 et 6 mai on
pouvait distinguer trois zones
contaminées
du nord au sud à l'ouest la plus faible
en bleu une seconde en jaune centré sur
le territoire de radioactivité moyenne
enfin une troisième à l'est en rouge
avec des taux relativement important le
service de protection contre les
rayonnements indiqué au maximum de 360
becquerel par litre
alors qu'on nous annonçait il ya une
semaine que jamais ces taux n'avait
dépassé 200 d'autres chercheurs
confirment aujourd'hui ses taux malgré
tout pas dangereux obtenu des niveaux
qui ont été détectées dans l'air par les
organismes spécialisés
il est peu probable que les niveaux que
nous allons trouver dans l'est home
nantes et qu'ils atteignent
des doses maximales admissibles sur
quelle région de france les nuages
radioactifs l'an passé il est d'abord
pénétré par le sud-est par l'italie et
il ya également eu un passage par la
partie de l'angleterre sous le l'ouest
de la france
cette vérité dissimuler ce silence ce
mensonge pose un vrai problème
le pouvoir du nucléaire en france la
france le pays du tout nucléaire le pays
le mieux équipé en centrales
électronucléaires qui produit grâce au
nucléaire
plus de 60 % de son énergie
effectivement voilà beaucoup de
questions alors avec nous en direct
depuis en direct de grenoble alain
carignon vous êtes ministre de
l'environnement monsieur k réunion
bonjour je vous alors comment expliquez
vous que les français étaient si mal
informés dans cette affaire parce que
nous journalistes nous avons essayé de
savoir et on nous a donné des
informations fausses
c'est le crois qu'il fallait d'abord
peut-être rappeler des choses très
simples il ya au fond d'eux il y a le
service de sûreté nucléaire qui dépend
des ministres de l'industrie et qui
compte et qui concerne le contrôle des
machines est un service à la disposition
également du public et puis il y a le
service de contrôle de la radioactivité
pour simplifier qui dépendent du
ministère de la santé et qui est le
service du professeur pellerin qui a été
donc souvent mis en cause en matière
d'information ça veut dire monsieur le
ministre que vous occupez de
l'environnement mais vous n'êtes ça ne
dépend pas de doute
alors attendez par contre ce qui est
qu'il veut ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que si l'information était mise en cause
jusque là le thermomètre c'est-à-dire
l'instrument qui permet de mesurer la
radioactivité ne l'a pas été parce qu'en
france il ya sur le territoire 130
thermomètre de mesure de la
radioactivité qui mesurent la
radioactivité dans l'air dans l'eau dans
le lait et qui la mesure en permanence
c'est à dire qu'il y ait tchernobyl ou
qu'il n'y ait pas tu en oeuvre donc on a
un instrument de mesure qui est
considéré comme fiable en france et en
europe c'est un élément très important
parce que ce n'est pas toujours le cas
dans les autres pays où il y avoit bien
une certaine cacophonie à l'intérieur
même des pays
pourquoi n'at-on pas dit la
radioactivité a augmenté tout simplement
l'a déjà les instruments de mesure
on diffuse
et tous les jours depuis le 28 avril
tous les jours en fin de soirée vers
minuit les séries comme sur pèlerins ont
diffusé les chiffres et puis samedi à
hier exactement le professeur pellerin a
pu présenter une carte qui est la
première carte coordonnées de du taux de
radioactivité publié par un pays
européen parce que pour la publier pour
des raisons techniques il faut un
certain délai puisqu'il faut que la la
radioactivité naturelle et elle est
prise en compte
donc elle a été publiée en france si
hier allé hier 15 jours après non mais
quotidiennement les chiffres ont été
publiés alors comme un quick et vous que
les français n'ont jamais su avait goûté
c'est aux médias de répercuter ces
chiffres c'est nous irons pas fait notre
travail nous les jours et ils ont été
diffusés maintenant je vais ajouter tout
de même quelque chose sur ce problème de
l'information qui est capital il est
capital parce que je crois que les
français sont majeurs et on doit le
savoir ils ont le droit de connaître
je crois que tout le monde s'accorde à
penser d'ailleurs le reportage montrait
que les taux tels qu'ils ont été hissés
sont développés les taux de
radioactivité ne sont pas dangereux
suivant les normes de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé nous suivant les
normes d'euratom dans les deux cas les
taupes qui sont déterminés en france ne
sont pas dangereux mais se pose le
problème de l'information et il faut
tirer l'expérience n'est ce pas de ceux
qui viennent se produire je crois que
dans tout événement il faut en tirer la
leçon
d'abord parce que un tel accident peut
se reproduire
il peut se reproduire parce qu'ils y
aillent il faut le dire 25 centrales à
peu près du même type que tchernobyl en
urss qu'il y en a dans les pays de l'est
l'incident peut aussi se reproduire en
europe bref donc il reste qu'on sera
mieux informés à la valeur moi je je je
propose puisque nous avons des
thermomètres des instruments de mesures
qui sont qualifiés je propose qu'une
cellule de coordination de l'information
qui soit organisée qui bénéficient des
informations de l'industrie et de la
santé et qui nous permettent si un
incident de ce type se produisent et
d'informer de façon coordonnée les
français avec tous les éléments
possibles car car je crois que en la
matière surtout s'il ya des mesures de
protection à prendre l'information est
un élément capital
ce serait une haute autorité de
l'information nucléaire
comme le réclament les écologistes par
exemple dont il faut que je te passe
sautée l'égide et sous quelle forme il
faut que cette coordination se fasse car
je crois que nous en avons les moyens en
france alors tout de même il y à déjà
donc une catastrophe de tchernobyl il ya
des informations qu'on aimerait
connaître par exemple est-ce que les
produits alimentaires en france ont subi
la radioactivité est ce qu'il ya des
produits par exemple que et et surgelés
et qui donc garderait cette
radioactivité est ce qu'on va savoir
tout ça vous avez les mesures qu'ils ont
qui ont été diffusées hier prouve que
donc c'est le sud est et l'alsace
lorraine c'est un peu l'ouest qui ont
été eu les taux de radioactivité plus
élevé que qui sont je le répète pour
l'instant je pense que c'est admis par
tous bien en dessous des spas des taux à
partir desquels il ya danger les
largement en dessous ça et 10 cents fois
en dessous des taux de danger dont alors
les allemands par exemple ont pris des
mesures il suffit de voir en alsace par
exemple d'un côté du rhin il ya des
mesures assez strictes de protection
prévention
de l'autre côté rien du tout ça vous
semble normal vous avez d'ailleurs la
communauté économique européenne il
reportage convient de voir le prouve
maintenant incertain certains accords
qui doit avoir lieu à l'extérieur de nos
frontières
je crois qu'il sera probablement le plus
facile à trouver et puis à l'intérieur
car maintenant vont se greffer les
intérêts économiques un peu divergents
des pays européens car il peut y avoir
là camouflage de ceux derrière la
sécurité ou la sûreté d'intérêt
économique il nous faut déterminer avec
beaucoup de précision alors nous
français de nous prendrons nous
donnerons il faut que nous puissions
diffusé quotidiennement les mesures de
contrôle qui sont effectués en france
qui existent et qui sont fiables
c'est vrai qu'en france il ya un lobby
pour le nucléaire la france un pays du
tout nucléaire est ce que vous engagez
monsieur le ministre a donné vraiment
toutes les informations dans ce domaine
oui je souhaite même que cette cellule
de coordination de l'information soit
placée sous l'égide du ministère de
l'environnement qui est là pour prévenir
et pour protéger
merci alain carignon merci de toutes ces
explications j'ajoute que la
mobilisation anti nucléaires se poursuit
en europe 15000 personnes défiler hier
soir à munich en allemagne
manifestations également athènes à rome
à lubjana en yougoslavie puis aussi à
gravelines dans le nord de la france des
écologistes ont occupé les marches de la
mairie pour protester contre
le manque de crédibilité des
informations officielles sur la centrale
nucléaire toute proche
le sport maintenant avec le tennis
décidément plus roland garros approche
plus noah apparaît au point hier soir à
forrest hill en demi-finale du tournoi
des champions
noah s'est payé le luxe de balade et
ivan lendl en deux sets 6 3 7 5 mais en
fait une victoire encore plus aisée que
ne l'indiqué le score gens ma mère très
belle victoire en effet de yannick noah
numéro sept mondial sur ivan lendl
numéro un
car si yannick noah l'a emporté c'est
autant grâce à ces balles très haute que
aussi aux erreurs de ivan lendl en ivan
lendl qui revenait à la compétition
après plus d'un mois d'arrêt sur une
blessure lors de son dernier tournoi et
qui a donc dû laisser échapper cette
accession à la finale au profit de
yannick noah
après la kim tae monte-carlo noir
dispute donc ce soir sa troisième finale
d'un grand tournoi et sera opposé à
guillermo vilas vainqueur de martyn
wright et 6 3 6 3 il est possible et il
faut l'espérer que noah l'emportent face
au vétéran entre guillemets vilas âgé de
30 ans de 33 ans
nous verrons cela gens d'autres
résultats brièvement oui avec un petit
événement hier soir c'est le premier
titre de champion de france remporté par
l'équipe d'orthez orthez est une petite
ville du béarn de 12000 habitants plus
connu pendant longtemps pour jouer son
basket sous son marché couvert mais si
hier soir avec le titre est bien le foie
gras a été scié à grosse bûche encore
d'autres informations jean louis des tas
d'informations avec la victoire aux
quatre jours de dunkerque d'un cinquième
étape du français vincent barteau arrivé
cette nuit de tabarly sur côte d'or 2e
de la 4e et dernière étape de la course
autour du monde en équipage lionel péan
le français s'il veut l'emporter doit
maintenant se dépêcher car ubs
switzerland est arrivé depuis maintenant
plus de 42 heures
et puis enfin cet après-midi grand prix
de monaco 15h30 c'est le plus beau
circuit du monde est l'un des plus beaux
grands prix remportés pour un pilote de
formule 1 prost l'a déjà remporté deux
fois de suite
il est pole position pourquoi pas deux
sans trois merci jean la politique hier
soir pour célébrer le cinquième
anniversaire de l'arrivée de la gauche
au pouvoir les socialistes avaient
organisé de grands banquets républicains
dans toute la france particulièrement
marqué celui de lyon avec hernu poperen
et surtout lionel jospin qui faisait sa
rentrée
dominique laurie la chiraquie ne sera
qu'une parenthèse formule de jean
poperen qui résume assez bien le climat
optimiste de ce banquier anniversaire du
10 mai charles hernu jean poperen et
lionel jospin ont affirmé que le ps
pouvait revenir au pouvoir
s'il réussissait sa mutation de venir à
parti rassemblement autour de françois
mitterrand qui pour ses leaders
socialistes est le meilleur candidat
pour 88
le premier secrétaire a saisi l'occasion
pour évoquer la cohabitation sommes avec
la co existence institutionnelle dans
une situation originale
il ne peut pas y avoir de guerre entre
les deux éléments du pouvoir exécutif
sinon ce serait la crise immédiate et le
peuple devrait trancher
il ne peut pas y avoir non plus de
compromissions politiques car les deux
hommes de cet exécutif incarnent des
politiques différentes et son fidèle a
des valeurs différentes
c'est donc nous le comprenons tous cette
situation ouverte le 16 mars 1986 une
situation transitoire une situation
précaire qui certes au nord le sens de
la démocratie de notre pays
le sens de la responsabilité des
dirigeants politiques mais qui ne durera
pas et que nous devons donc mettre à
profit pour la perspective de 1988
analyse identique à roanne
laurent fabius n'exclut pas que les
premiers accrocs surviennent dès
l'automne entre le président et le
gouvernement voir au sein de la majorité
car at il lancé la corrèze le lyonnais
et l'auvergne ont visiblement beaucoup
de mal à cohabiter
a marseille il hommage à gaston defferre
les obsèques du maire de marseille
auront lieu demain mais de très nombreux
marseillais ont déjà défilé depuis hier
devant la dépouille de leur grand homme
olivier lerner a marseille des draps
bleus et blancs sur la façade de la
mairie en signe de deuil
depuis hier soir les marseillais se
recueille dans la chapelle ardente où
reposent gaston defferre
on attend plusieurs centaines de
milliers de personnes pour les
funérailles qui ont lieu demain
du jamais vu à marseille les querelles
de succession ont cessé dans l'immédiat
marseille se tait pour veiller son mer
3500 personnes ont été invitées à titre
personnel deux cent mille marseillais
vont accompagner gaston defferre jusqu'à
sa dernière demeure
la cérémonie des obsèques qui débutera
demain à 11 heures les allocutions
seront prononcées par le premier adjoint
au maire jean victor cordonnier lionel
jospin et jacques chaban delmas
tout marseille sera au rendez vous
je demande pas tant quarante deux années
mujib il a beaucoup aidé des jeunes vu
le port et la plage la plage jusqu'à la
peinture c'est lui les hôpitaux c'est
lui
j'aime beaucoup dhayani brou paul gaston
defferre aura passé trente trois ans de
sa vie à la mairie de marseille
les marseillais commencent à réaliser
qu'une page de l'histoire de leur ville
est définitivement tournée
en bref dans l'actualité internationale
londres expulse trois diplomates syriens
margaret thatcher a donc franchi un
nouveau pas spectaculaire dans sa
croisade contre le terrorisme
en espagne des terroristes présumés
arrêtés il était membre d'une
organisation anti sioniste ils
s'apprêtaient à commettre des attentats
contre des entreprises américaines à
madrid
la météo tout de suite les prévisions de
laurent boussier laurent et willy côté
météo pas de problème on a toujours
quelques nuages au cid honor pardon et
un temps ensoleillé au sud un solide y
avait quand même une petite exception
sur le sud-ouest regarder la carte du
temps prévu pour cet après midi sur
l'aquitaine quelques quelques arrivées
d'entrée d'aires marines devraient
donner un ciel où déjà un ciel
légèrement nuageux de quand même
quelques éclaircies et surtout pas
surtout pas de pluie sur tout le reste
de la moitié sud donc du soleil de la
chaleur nous le verrons dans quelques
instants
alors que sur la moitié nord ça va un
tout petit peu moins bien il ya des
nuages mais toute façon il n'y aura pas
de précipitation côté température et
bien ils sont encore en petite hausse
regardez les températures prévues pour
cet après-midi de 16 degrés à cherbourg
jusqu'à 22 degrés à mulhouse sur la
moitié nord 20 degrés à paris c'est tout
à fait agréable et de 22 mai jusqu'à 27
degrés sur la moitié sud 27 degrés à
toulouse 27 degrés à nîmes une chaleur
qui bénéficie à toute l'europe puisque
cet après midi il fera 23 degrés à
genève et 28° à lisbonne
vous saurez tout quand je vous ai dit
quand je vous aurais dit qu'en plus hier
après midi il a fait 36 degrés à marc hs
36° voyez là on a encore le temps de le
voir venir la chronique c'était hier la
chronique de bernard marchetti souvenez
vous au moment du 11 novembre dernier on
avait appris qu'un poilus de la grande
guerre attendait sa décoration sa
médaille militaire depuis 1916 l'année
deux actions héroïques émotion chez les
anciens combattants qui réclament pour
leur camarade
alors que s'est-il passé après c'est ce
que va nous raconter
bernard marchetti mais d'abord voici le
reportage que nous diffusions le 10
novembre 85 précisément
oui je suis un peu confuse que vous me
verrez c'est à ma petite personne calme
parce que enfin bouger comme moi je ne
suis pas là projet me plaît
lynch éviter on y sort pas à 20 ans ce
petit père tranquille a risqué sa vie
pour prévenir les artilleurs français
qui tirait sur sa propre compagnie 18 à
l'après midi les 242 wallemme chargeait
nous tiraient dessus de son cours
et comme agent de liaison
je suis allé en rampant de modèles
atterri d'urgence qu'ils allongent de
dire que je suis arrivé quand je suis
arrivée là fihri j'avais mon cash
karachi al-rajma cartouchière harrachis
drogue par des balles mma capote tout
est de 10,9 tôt je n'avais pas une
égratignure
ça a été un miracle le jour même on lui
promet la médaille militaire
et puis la guerre finie on l'oubli à
l'époque cette chapelle n'y a pas deux
mais vous avez le sentiment sa peau
c'était une belle satisfaction et puis
parfois j'avais quand on est jaloux
bildt en page et puis vu j'ai plus pensé
après ça ferait plaisir de les avoir
aujourd'hui ses décorations chercheur
présente le match de vannes comment
dirais je
dans l'opération ne croyez pas non plus
pas deux mois après ce reportage
monsieur edouard bozier a été décoré de
la médaille militaire par le général
commandant la 42e région prise d'armes
cérémonial grandiose à la caserne d'un
beau ville de poitiers
c'est le 15 janvier 1986 le
récipiendaire est dans sa 90e année le
soldat edouard bozier agent de liaison
aux soixante treizième régiment
d'infanterie était dans sa vingtième
année lorsque lui fut promise la
médaille militaire après son action
d'éclat c'était le 18 janvier 1916
soixante dix ans à trois jours près se
sont écoulés entre la promesse et sa
réalisation il n'est jamais trop tard il
suffit de vivre longtemps mais on dirait
que tout à coup la france veuille
rattraper le temps perdu et pays avec
les intérêts sa dette de reconnaissance
envers l'ancien héros de 1916 jeudi
dernier à l'occasion du 8 mai edouard
bozier a reçu une deuxième décoration la
médaille du combattant
encore une belle cérémonie m'a dit
monsieur bozier avec le concours de la
musique des saint cyriens de coëtquidan
et la troisième médaille est en route
la croix de la légion d'honneur la
demande a été faite par le général
commandant la quarante deuxième région
militaire
mais le long cheminement administratif
qui aboutira à présenter le dossier la
signature du président de la république
inquiète un peu monsieur bozier on l'a
averti il faut en général trois ans il
m'a dit j'ai attendu 70 ans pour la
médaille militaire
j'essayerai d'attendre encore trois ans
pour la légion d'honneur mais je ne
promets rien à mon âge
alors pour garder le moral et la forme
il baisse son jardin il joue du violon
tout va bien d'ailleurs la preuve il
conduit sa voiture comme un jeune homme
je lui ai demandé et la guerre 39 45
comment s'est-elle passée pour vous
réponse j'ai fait de la résistance
j'avais monté un petit réseau sur la
ligne de démarcation j'ai sauvé beaucoup
de monde
une nuit j'ai même fait passer 50
personnes d'un coup en zone libre
edouard bozier n'y a peut-être pas pensé
mais la médaille de la résistance plus
de quarante ans après ce ne serait pas
mal non plus vous ne croyez pas non vous
ne croyez pas le festival de cannes
les festivités se poursuivent bien sûr
sur la croisette pour une fois nos
antennes 2010 nous allons oublier un peu
l'actualité immédiate et prendre un peu
de recul pendant les premiers jours du
festival
noël mamère s'est promené à cannes il a
respiré l'air des coulisses du cinéma il
nous rapporte une lettre la loi c'est
donc marc photographe estimait que
j'aurais été un chef opérateur fait
extraordinaire
il m'a fait faire des essais au moment
de la passe du boulanger contre ma
volonté car je lui expliquais que
j'étais un homme des photos arrêté
uniquement très plastique dont j'ai
toujours trouvé que le mouvement
c'est un point de vue que je n'étais pas
plastique coupée tout plasticité
mais ça paraît incroyable à beaucoup de
gens j'estime que je pourrai que j'avais
toutes les capacités pour être un
photographe de films valable n'est pas
un opérateur de mouvements absolument
pas ce petit homme avec lequel je marche
s'appelle roger corbeau sa profession
photographe de plateau pendant cinquante
années il a consacré sa vie aux acteurs
et aux stars en posant sur eux ce regard
d'aigle qui ont fait un génie
aujourd'hui le 7e art auquel il a tant
donné lui rend hommage à cannes corbeau
l'exigeant corbeau le maniaque corbeau
l'artisan de la lumière pour provoquer
le rêve dans un instantané corbeau le
révélateur des stars telles que vous les
rives et roger corbeau
combien d'années entre cette photo de
vous sur un plateau et ce live que nous
visons maintenant eh bien je ne sais
absolument pas calculés noël c'est une
photo qui a été fait en 1956 à potsdam
lorsque je tournais avec raymond hulu
les sorcières de salem
alors vous vous êtes un meilleur matière
à titien que moi vous allez me souffler
ce qui nous est arrivé de devenir
amoureux des femmes que vous avez
photographié de certaines bien sûr bien
sûr j'étais très très amoureux de faye
dunaway maria casarès elle s'en souvient
très très profond
stéphane audran que je trouve d'une
telle beauté
peux-tu un peu serré s'il te plaît c'est
un peu en restant toujours sur le visage
de celle de zurich
je trouve prenez tendues stéphane ne pas
réussir à voir quelque chose du bien là
c'est vrai que c'est l'humour du coup
j'ai chez moi qui n'étais fin c'est tout
je me sens bien du tout la cellule
femmes
stephen fry gold 1 pourquoi il faut
jamais alors avec toi il refaisait la
séquence
il vous demander de recommencer à vous
mettre dans des états et on s'y met et
finalement pour lui faire plaisir et en
même temps parce qu'il était tellement
dense en 30e on s'y mettait
est ce que ça vous a apporté quelque
chose dans votre carrière de présenter
des photos de roger corbeau de vous ah
oui ça m'a fait beaucoup plaisir je
regrette seulement de ne pas l'avoir
fait plus parce que souvent j'avais
l'occasion ils me demandaient et puis
moi je partais et puis maintenant il
veut et ça je regrette parce que les
souvenirs de les belles photos que j'ai
par exemple derniers films que j'ai
faits sévir et naudières avec lui chez
et photos absolument admirable et
finalement vous savez quand vous pensez
un film vous pensez un vieux film qu'à
50 ans vous pensez aux photos plus qu'à
qu'un décès n'ont évidemment on vous
pensez aux belles photos qui sont restés
de ce film est qui et qui le représente
la région qu'on est grand
colonne vertébrale fracturée en de zone
l'acta gens
au fil du jeu noël en marchant je sais
les mâles delà de la guerre
mende a porté sur l'echez
le plot mettez vous une question
pourquoi avez vous fait pour moi
une exception
roger corbeau vous y avait ce qu'on peut
appeler une gueule
est ce que vous avez eu envie de faire
du cinéma mais aussi non alors
sincèrement jamais on m'a fait tourner
en maths et tournées précise evra à
gauche de cette drôle de gueule oui j'ai
tourné au il ya très très longtemps j'ai
tourné un film avec talent fait que
kafarneh j'ai tourné également un rôle
important d'ailleurs de computer dans le
procès de moscou est ce là j'allais
d'une page et demie jeu des petits gars
béante à liberté 10 comme partenaire ce
n'est pas un regard roger corbeau s'est
fait mystère de kent finalement c'est
vrai si mal c'est plutôt agréable ces
terrasses beaucoup de monde mais bien
nous soleil
je trouve ça très jeunes du genre le
soleil en moi je vous tends mon salut je
suis un homme de l'est
je n'aime pas le soleil mais de voir ce
spectacle ces gens tellement d'eau
tellement marrant habitue n'importe
comment
très différents tous je trouve c'est un
spectacle dans la nuit même
et comme la vie n'est pas toujours
joyeuses emballages
je prends mon combat de jouvence dans
tout ça je dors est ce que ça vous donne
envie quelquefois de reprendre votre
appareil photo pour absolument si
absolument pas non ça me donne aucune
envie non je suis arrivé à un point où
j'estime je ne veux pas devenir un vieux
cheval de cire que l'on billy's car dix
ans pour monter sur un qi s'est encore
classé souffla non alors là j'ai des je
suis relativement relativement paisible
monsieur levrette au graff comme dirait
brialy le voilà donc célébrée à votre
tour vous devenez la cible des objectifs
pour que le gain qui n'aiment pas les
mondanités vous devez être un peu gêné
par tant de représentations
le verrier
vous avez horreur de la foule
mais comme le bain de vos photos quand
la foule vous aime son bain est bon à
prendre
ce qui vous est un homme heureux ce soir
bien sûr c'est vraiment très très adroit
je traite faisant mais bien sûr mais je
ne donne pas l'air étant donné que je
suis toujours il ya cette inquiétude qui
est en moi perpétuellement vous en avez
rendez compte d'ailleurs je ne suis pas
un homme du micro mais lorsque vous avez
la gentillesse de m'interroger je
regarde vous aux yeux et ça m'aide
beaucoup
oui parce qu'il ya une telle indulgence
et donc je ne peux être qu'heureux noël
mamère vous le retrouverez demain cette
même place et pour toute la semaine pour
antenne 2010 auparavant
aujourd'hui d'autres rendez vous à être
l'information sportive 18h30 sera gérard
holtz pour stade 2 et puis à 20h vous
retrouverez claude sérillon excellente
après-midi sur antenne 2